Você sabia que aquele cafezinho
instantâneo prático do dia a dia pode
estar prejudicando sua visão? Pois é,
olha só o que acabaram de descobrir. Um
estudo gigantesco com 500.000 pessoas
mostrou que quem toma café instantâneo
tem maior risco de desenvolver
degeneração macular, aquela doença que
vai deixando a visão embaçada no centro.
Sabe? O mais curioso é que isso não
acontece com quem toma café coado
normal, só com instantâneo mesmo. Veja
bem, o problema não é o café em si, é
que o instantâneo passa por um processo
industrial pesado, com temperaturas
altíssimas que formam a crilamida, uma
substância tóxica. Fora os aditivos,
conservantes e até o açúcar escondido
que colocam ali. É mais um
ultraprocessado disfarçado de produto
inofensivo. Então fica a dica, troca
esse instantâneo por um café coado
tradicional. Sua visão e sua saúde
agradece. E me conta, você toma qual
tipo de café no seu dia a dia?